for more now we are joined by cbs news
chief legal correspondent jan crawford
who is at the supreme court
jan let's start with amy coney barrett
what else can you tell us about her
well i mean she was a highly regarded
federal appeals court judge a former law
professor at
notre dame where she was considered a
brilliant academic and her writings
really reflect that she sees the law
a lot like her old boss justice antonin
scalia she worked for him
as a law clerk all of these things kind
of suggest
to republicans that this nomination
would be a home run
and democrats feel just the opposite one
of the other names that had been heard
before was judge barbara lagoa
who is from florida some people thought
trump might go in that direction because
of that being a battleground state
are we seeing a difference in ideology
also between these two
no not really i mean as ben said uh
judge barrett had
long been the presumptive front-runner
because the president had already met
with her and then went with brett
kavanaugh i think one of the things that
really worked in her favor
was that as he said she had already been
vetted and now because the white house
wants to move so quickly
the fact that she went through this
brutal confirmation
uh hearing for the seventh circuit court
of appeals the chicago-based court
really worked in her favor they saw that
she had gone through the fire and she
stood strong
they knew she's been an academic so
she's well-versed in a lot of the
constitutional law issues she's going to
be asked about in the hearing so
time really also was on her side but
there was a huge push for judge lagoa
during this whole process not only
because of the politics but people
believe that she's
also a very staunch conservative jen
michelle here uh what about the timeline
for confirmation well it's going to be
something i mean there's going to be two
days
that you have to keep in mind 38 and 99
38 days till the election at 99 days
until this
session of congress concludes can they
do it yeah i mean they've got the votes
they say
is it unprecedented no i mean there's
been times in the past where they've
done it really quickly congress has
getting a nominee on to the supreme
court justice ginsburg herself
really around 50 days from the time of
nomination to confirmation justice
o'connor under 40 days
but in modern times those nominations
take a lot longer it is all-out war when
you've got a supreme court confirmation
uh in these days and so recently it's
taken more like two and a half to three
months and
obviously that's a lot longer than the
time frame that they've got but they say
they have the votes
so if republicans hold together it's
going to be very difficult for democrats
to do anything about it
jan the list of justices have acted
differently on the bench
once they've gotten there versus what a
president or others expected of them
is very long can you talk about that a
little bit yes and it usually is for
republican nominees jeff i mean it's
it's usually you don't see someone that
the democrats nominate get up here and
all of a sudden they start voting
conservative for republicans and
conservatives this has been a long
source of frustration you've got
a republican president nominating a
justice who's going to be a staunch
conservative
they get to washington and next thing
you know you know they start getting
influenced and started drifting to the
left you've seen that over and over
again whether it was
justice david suiter justice anthony
kennedy even justice
sandra day o'connor so the promise of a
conservative supreme court
has always fallen short for
conservatives but now they believe
that this may finally be the time if
judge barrett is confirmed to the
supreme court where they would have a
solid majority
six conservative nominees uh which
potentially could get you
to a majority even if one of them
decided like justice like the chief
justice john roberts did
to go over and vote with liberals in
controversial cases
okay jan crawford as always thank you
very much